Your body consists of many atoms and 7 octalons to be precise. Constitute
37 trillion cells in your body which are actually much smaller than you think.
The cells that make up your stomach renew every 5 days, and this is logical because stomach acid
You can analyze the minerals, the outer layers of your skin known as the skin, known as the skin and fall
Every two weeks to 4 weeks, meaning after a year you will lose about 0.7 kg of dead skin
Few cells live with you for life These cells are the inner lens cells of your eyes
Heart muscle cells, and nerve cells in the cerebral cortex.
It is a great responsibility to create and save memory
While the brain looks small, all those wrinkles are for good reason. Publish it
Your brain will be the size of a pillow. This is good by
Of the neurotransmitters that form your memory. On the other hand, studies showed that after 2500 assistance
Picture Within three seconds participants can remember if they have seen one of the pictures
With accuracy of 92%
Do not believe your eyes? Maybe because you're 10% off your day
Can actually distinguish between 2.3 to 7.5 million colors. Your nose is capable of distinguishing
Between 1 trillion different smells, at the same time your fingers can feel like small hills
The size of 13 nm - this 7500X smaller than the diameter of a human hair. And while
Do not think too much with your pinky finger but without it you will lose 50% of the strength of your hand
The middle fingers help you to tweak and catch things
But it is the thumb and the pink that give your hand power
Because you tie your right hand to the left, this is about the size of your heart and beating 100,000 times a day
It pumps 5.5 liters per pulse, nearly 3 million liters of blood per year
If you live for 75 years, 90 Olympic swimming pools will be filled.
After your death, the human body decomposes after 4 minutes of your death.
This process is called self-digestion. In this process, enzymes and bacteria are oxidized.
Actually, about 3-5 pounds of bacteria are formed in the unclean mouth
100 million to 1 billion bacteria can grow on all teeth - and you have 32 years
Some of us have bacteria in their mouth more than the inhabitants of the earth
If this makes you feel weak, do not worry, your bones are incredibly strong!
When the pressure tolerance is tested at a rate of one second, a person weighing 83 kg can measure the size of the shoe
16,000 people can stand on his bones at one time, is of course, if there is enough space
From the bones of our ancestors, we can extract DNA to identify them. but if
We took all of your DNA from your body to eat, which could extend to about 10 billion miles
You can extend from the ground to Pluto go and back, and if you take both veins, capillaries
And arterioles, and their separation
For each other you will die
Do you have a question that you want to answer?
Ask in the comments box, on Twitter or Facebook
If you want to go behind the scenes, and ideas about the upcoming episodes you can follow us on our personal account on Twitter and Twitter
And participated in the channel for more scientific videos